the United Nations says sexual violence
is increasingly being used as a weapon
of war in Sudan attacks have become
widespread as the Army and paramilitary
Rapid support forces battle for control
more than 130 cases have officially been
reported but rights activists say the
real number is much higher Ahmed Idris
is in neighboring Chad with Sudanese
refugees who fled the conflict Ahmed
will come to you in a moment first
though let's go to Hibba Morgan in
carum you've been working on this for a
while Hiba tell us what you've been
finding
out well we know that the cases that
have been reported to a governmental
units here in the capital Kum uh and
elsewhere around the country just
represents the tip of the iceberg that's
what the unit has told us that's what
rights groups are saying and they say
that that's because of fear of
repercussions now many people uh
especially women are still in Conflict
zones they're still trapped in the
fighting between the Sudanese Army and
the paramilitary rapid support forces
here in the capital Kum and uh between
the uh the their their tribes and the
militias and the rsf in other parts of
the country such as darur so they are
concerns they security concerns by those
who have uh suffered sexual violence at
the hands of uh armed groups or rather
whether it's the paramilitary rapid
support forces or militias and so not
many cases get reported but the few get
that that do uh get reported there
always horror stories behind them
many people trapped in the conflict
between Sudan's Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces fear
losing their lives to a stray bullet or
artillery shelling but for some women
another fear has surfaced the threat of
sexual
violence we were going to pick up things
from our home there was a rapid support
forces checkpoint on the road they took
us to a building about four people
carrying guns took me to a bedroom they
said either you give in or we take your
life one pushed me on the bed the other
gripped my wrists and a third was
holding my legs they took turns raping
me afterwards they told me to leave but
I couldn't walk the rsf commander was
questioning me asking if I was a spy and
I kept saying I was a civilian then he
raped me at gunpoint when he was done he
took me outside and threw me towards the
men and said threaten her with guns so
she doesn't speak they said don't talk
about this if you do we'll kill you most
survivors say their attackers were
members of the rapid support forces the
paramilitary group is also accused of
forcing women into sexual slavery in the
western daro region a government agency
the unit for combating violence against
women has documented more than3 cases of
rape and sexual violence since the
fighting began in April
while dozens of cases have been reported
in Conflict zones the unit says that
those do not reflect the real number of
survivors of sexual abuse and that shame
and stigma are preventing many cases
from being
reported rights groups say sexual
violence is being used to terrorize
communities and that some assaults
appear to be racially motivated the UN
has called for
accountability the parties to the
conflict must take full responsibility
for preventing any acts of sex ual and
gender-based violence committed by their
members and should issue command orders
that prohibit sexual
violence allegations of these crimes
must be investigated and perpetrators
must be held
accountable rape as a weapon of war is
not new for decades armed groups have
been accused of violations in darur and
other areas to date no one has been held
accountable few believe this time will
be different
hia Morgan Al jazer
Kum so people especially women who are
still trapped still have the fear of
reporting that they have been sexually
abused uh or violated by their
perpetrators now we have spoken to
doctors right groups also they say that
cases as young as 9 years old have been
reported uh to be sexually assaulted by
uh woring parties here especially the
paramilitary rapid support forces it is
worth noting that the rapid support
Force has previously denied being
involved in uh in these allegations but
many survivors say that that is not true
and they say they want accountability
but as long as the fighting is ongoing
and with no judicial uh or
accountability mechanism in place they
doubt that they will be seeing any
accountability anytime soon Hiba thank
you very much for bringing us those
voices that's Hibba Morgan reporting
from carum let me turn now to Ahmed
Idris you're in adre in Chad Ahmed jet
just near the sudanes border hundreds of
thousands of Sudanese refugees have fled
to Chad what have they shared about
sexual violence in
Sudan shocking accounts SEL I can tell
you shocking accounts yesterday I uh on
Sunday we met some of the victims and it
was quite a struggle for me to finish
the interview the account of one um of
the victims as Survivor was so shocking
that she couldn't even conclude the
interview she was crying throughout
first of all this uh her account of a
rape four months ago was not the first
and she was raped last year just weeks
before her wedding and this year too she
was targeted simply because her husband
was an activist and the account she was
giving us was so harrowing that it was
so difficult for us to even conduct the
interview and now doctors and health
workers in these camps are telling us
this is just a small fraction of the
number they suspect that thousands of
cases are happening have already
happened and simply because they noticed
depression and uh sexual violence and of
course rape is such a huge issue among
communities here that many of the
victims don't are not willing to talk
about joining me to talk more about this
cases is Dr Fel abdurahman who himself
was displaced by the violence latest
violence in Dar for he works at the
General Hospital in Jan and he HS the
women and children unit of that hospital
he's been working as a volunteer doctor
in these camps doctor thank you for
joining us uh how widespread what have
you observed how widespread is these uh
cases I mean are these cases in camps
like this uh there are hundred and
thousands of cases here in the C but
because of cultural taboo and even the
victims they feel that it's a shame to
talk about such stuff to tell family and
even Community you have been rap they
feel shame that's why we don't have an
accurate statistic but I myself I not a
lot of cases and when they suffered from
mental problems they will come and seek
a medical care and even they use it to
suffer from medical problems not only
sexual violence they use to suffer from
such issues and even other peoples you
know because being Survivor from armed
conflict area later it going to affect
in your health now doctor you're talking
about giving them treatment do we have
enough facilities we're talking about
more than 400,000 refugees in eastern
child alone do we have enough resources
like counselors like doctors like
medicines some of them have been damaged
for example example some of the cases we
met they are talking about infections
and it's it's so difficult for them to
sort of relate this to doctors like you
do we have enough facilities to deal
with these cases I mean victims of
sexual violence no unfortunately we
don't have enough facilities and even
health personnel and even social worker
to provide such services for them but
absolutely they're in need of such
Services regarding psychological support
and even Sometimes some of them they are
in need of a medical intervention I
myself and a colleague of mine we were
working on this on sudanes refugee camp
Clinic we use it to provide health care
for other people and even psychological
support for such victims but
unfortunately we have been stopped
working because of absence of Channel
support for our C Clinic thank you Dr
Fel ABD rman uh basically what doctors
and health workers are telling us here
is that they could offer some help as
long as they have these facilities to
deal with such cases but unfortunately
these cases uh these facilities are not
available they were talking about people
women young girls as young as 10 13 15
who have to run away back into Jan a
danger zone in order to run away from
members of their families because of the
shame they feel and of course the guilt
they felt they were partly responsible S
Ahmed Idris thanks to you and your team
for being in audre to bring us this
vital story and thank than your guest as
well this hour we appreciate it